[موسيقى]
صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
تيك توك في قفص الاتهام الكونجرس يهاجم
التطبيق ومبررات رئيسه التنفيذي تحظى بدعم
الصين
مدعي عامه يرفض الموصوله امام الكونجرس
للكشف عن نتائج التحقيق بقضيه ترامب
[موسيقى]
البنتاجون يقرر تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
ابرامز من المخزون العسكري واوروبا تتعهد
بمليون قذيفه صاروخيه
بعد عامين من الحرب
تمدد تمد يدها لجبهه تيغراي والبرلمان
الاثيوبي يشطبها من قائمه الارهاب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه في شد وجذب
سياسي حول مستقبل تطبيق تيك توك مثل اليوم
الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه شوتشيو امام
الكونغرس الامريكي واكد ان شركته تواجه
الكثير من المفاهيم الخاطئه وان بيانات
المستخدمين وخاصه المراهقين تحظى بالحمايه
اللازمه شيو نفا ايضا ما اثير عن تسرب
بيانات المستخدمين في الولايات المتحده
مؤكدا انها معززه بانظمه حمايه وفيما يخص
الخوارزميات التي تشغل التطبيق سلط الضوء
على ارشادات السلامه الجديده لتيك توك
لابعاد الانظار عن اي ضغوط امريكيه بهدف
اجبار المنصه على تسليمها
لدينا اكثر من مليار مستخدم بينهم 150
مليونا في امريكا وضعنا تدابير لمنع ارسال
رسائل نصيه للمستخدمين دون 16 عاما ولا
نعارض اي مساله تتعلق بالخصوصيه تم بناء
جدران حمايه للبيانات الامريكيه وباشراف
موظفين امريكيين وهم فقط من يمكنهم الوصول
للبيانات الامريكيه التي ستكون تحت رقابه
الوكالات الامنيه الامريكيه اننا ناخذ
المخاوف الاميركيه على محمل الجد ولن نسمح
بالتلاعب ببيانات المستخدمين من اي جهه
مسؤوليتنا تتمثل في حمايه المستخدمين
الامريكيين وملتزمون بذلك نحن الشركه
الوحيده التي تقدم بيانات شفافه لسنا شركه
حكوميه
من الاستثمارات اجنبيه
واثناء هذه الجلسه جلسه الاستماع لرئيس
التنفيذي لتيك توك اتهم الكونجرس التطبيق
الصيني بنشر فيديو يحمل تهديد لرئيسه جلسه
الاستماع وان الحزب الشيوعي الصيني قد
يخترق هواتف الامريكيين عبره طلب ايضا
التطبيق بالضبط المحتوى وعدم تحوله لاداه
تجسس الى جانب عدم تزويد الحكومه الصينيه
ببيانات المستخدمين
الحكومه الصينيه من جهتها اعلنت نيتها
معارضه خطط امريكيه محتمله لاجبار الشركه
الصينيه المالكه لتطبيق تيك توك على بيعه
لشركه اخرى بسبب مخاطر امنيه كما حذرت
بكين من ان مثل هذه الخطوه ستضر بثقه
المستثمرين في امريكا
[موسيقى]
تيك توك ما زال عالقا في صراع جيوسياسي
بين واشنطن وبكين وظهر الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه تيك توك
شوتشيو امام لجنه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
لاقناعهم بالتراجع عن مخططاتهم لحظر
التطبيق بالكامل في الولايات المتحده او
اجبار تيك توك على الانفصال عن الشركه
الام باي دانس
المسؤول الصيني واجه وابلا من الاسئله من
الممثلين في اللجنه حول سياسات حمايه
البيانات وما اذا كانت ملكيه التطبيق من
قبل شركه تكنولوجيا صينيه تشكل خطرا على
الامن القومي الامريكي تشو يدخل عش
الدبابير بقدميه قريبا لكن لديه خطه
لتفادي اللدغات خلال شهادته الاولى امام
الكونجرس سلطت شو الضوء على ارشادات
السلامه الجديده لتيك توك لابعاد الانظار
عن اي ضغوط امريكيه بهدف اجبار المنصه على
تسليم خوارزميتها
وستتضمن جهود تيك توك منع المستخدمين تحت
سن السادسه عشره من ارسال رسائل مباشره
وذلك لحمايه المراهقين بالاضافه الى تكثيف
اجراءات لازاله المحتوى العنيف من المنصه
وتركز محاولات تشو لطمانه الامريكيين على
مشروع تكساس ايضا الذي يمثل وعدا بحمايه
بيانات المستخدمين الامريكيين عبر حفظ
بياناتهم في شركات محليه مثل راكل
ولكن مع كل هذه الجهود يبدو ان الولايات
المتحده ستظل دائما قلقه طالما تحتفظ بكين
بسيطرتها على تيك توك
ومن ناحيه اخرى يرى ان الصين تفضل خروج
تيك توك من السوق الامريكي بدلا من بيعها
للولايات المتحده
معنى ان واشنطن مايك المستشار الاول للامن
الوطني والسبراني في اهلا بك معنا مايك في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه بعد هذه الجلسه
جلسه الاستجواب القاسيه
لمدير تيك توك امام الكونجرس ما سيكون
مصير التطبيق الصيني في امريكا
كنت اعلم الاجابه ماذا سوف يحل بمستقبل
تيك توك لكنت قد اصبحت رجلا ثريا من الصعب
ان نتنبا بما قد يحدث ولكن من الواضح ان
هناك اجماع بين الحزبين بما في ذلك البيت
الابيض على ان تطبيق تيك توك
لا يمكن السماح به ووجوده في الولايات
المتحده دون ان يكون منفصلا عن الصين
والحل لا يعد مقبولا لمالك
الشركه الملكه بايدنس التي كانت قد دفعت
الى اكتتاب او تسجيل اكثر من 150 مليون
مستخدم اي نصف البلاد يستخدمون هذا
التطبيق اناس كثريه يحققون معيشتهم
وقوت يومهم من هذا التطبيق لدى من الصعب
ان نعلم ما الذي قد يحدث نتيجه هذه الجلسه
وانا لا اعلم صراحه فهناك عده سياسات قد
يتم تمريرها لكن كل من هذه قد لا تكون
كافيا لاسعاد الجميع حقا مايك انه سؤال
المليون دولار يعني مصير تيك توك ماذا
سيحل به ولكن تيك توك تحاول طمانه
المسؤولين الامريكيين حتى لا يحضر التطبيق
هي انفقت الكثير تقول على
شركه اوراكل لتخزين بيانات
المستخدمين الامريكيين لتطبيق تيك توك
الامريكيين هل هذا يطمئن الجانب الامريكي
بانه بيانات المستخدمين الامريكيين في
امان لا تصل الى الحكومه الصينيه
من الواضح ان هذا غير صحيح ولم يستطيعوا
حتى اللحظه اقناعي صانعي سياسات بمشروع
بروجكت تكسس
وحتى الاشهر القليله الماضيه كنا كانت
هناك مداولات بين المشرعين لاعطاء قدره
وصول لرمزي
تيك توك ليكون متاحا للحكومه الامريكيه
وحتى هذه اللحظه لا يمكن لا توجد الطمانه
كافيه للحكومه الامريكيه بسلامه هذا
التطبيق وكل ما قدم لا يعد كافيا للولايات
المتحده من وجهه نظر
من وجهه نظر معظم
الموجودين في الكونغرس والبيت الابيض
طالما ان بيض دانس هي التي تسيطر على على
غالبيه الحصص والشركه ويتم امتلاكها من
قبل اناس صيني امواطنين الصينيين فهذا غير
كافي حتى اللحظه لاعطاء الطمئن المطلوبه
بان المواطنين الامريكيين سوف يكونون
بمؤمن من الحزب الشيوعي الصيني نقطه هامه
جدا هناك من يرى ان الحظر حتى لو جرى
الحذر الكامل لتيك توك في امريكا فان هذا
سيزيد من شعبيته فقط عندما حضر تنزيل
التطبيق على هواتف المسؤولين الحكوميين
لوحظ ازدياد شعبيه تيك توك اكثر في امريكا
وطبعا هناك وسائل تقنيه الان لتجاوز الحجم
او الحظر مثل الفي بي ان هل الا تخشى انه
في حال حضر تماما تيك توك فانه
سيزداد انتشارا اكثر
هذا سؤال وجيه
بصوره شخصيه فانني اشكك بان الشعبيه هذا
التطبيق قد تزداد واذا ما حدث
حظر فانت محق فان هناك اناس كثر سوف
يكونون من الفطنه بما يكفي لتجاوز هذا
التطبيق باستخدامي في بي ان على نفسي من
والي ما تقوم به دول اخرى في انحاء العالم
في روسيا حيث يصل الناس الى هذا التطبيق
الذي يعده محظورا من قبل حكومتهم هناك لذا
قد يكونوا من قبيل المفاجاه ان نرى ان
الولايات المتحده سوف تزيد شعبيه
المستخدمين لان اصانعي السياسات
السيبرانيه بما في ذلك انا واحد منهم
ينظرون الى هذه الدول القمعيه مثل روسيا
التي تستخدم التقنيات
حول هذا التطبيق لكن معظم المستخدمين
الدوليين لا يتمتعون بالقدره الكافيه من
الذكاء التكنولوجي لتحميل في بي ان
والتلاعبي
حول القيود التي قد تفرد
وهناك اناس كثر الذين سوف يتمتعون بقدره
الوصول الى التطبيق لكن الغالبيه العظمى
من المستخدمين قد يتراجعون من هذا التطبيق
شكرا جزيلا لك مايك
المستشفى الاول لمن الوطني والسبراني في
كنت معنا من واشنطن العاصمه
في ذات القضيه ايد البرلمان البريطاني
اليوم ما اقرته الحكومه في حظر تطبيق تيك
توك ما يحرم المشرعين من الوصول الى تطبيق
الفيديو الصيني عبر شبكه الانترنت الخاصه
به وقال مجلس العموم ان التطبيق سيحذر على
كل الاجهزه المرتبطه بالبرلمان والشبكه
البرلمانيه الاوسع نطاقا للامن السيبراني
كونه يمثل اولويه قصوى وسيبقى بامكان
المشرعين استخدام تيك توك على هواتفهم
الخاصه لكن ليس عند الاتصال بشبكه
الانترنت الخاصه بالبرلمان البريطاني
[موسيقى]
في الولايات المتحده تتجهل الانظار الى
نيويورك بانتظار جيلاء الغموض عن مصير
الرئيس السابق دوما ترامب ايام قليله
ستحدد معالم المرحله السياسيه المقبله في
وقت تتعالى التحذيرات من انعكاسات كارثيه
على البلاد دق الجمهوريون ناقوس الخطر من
تداعيات توجيه تهم جنائيه بحق رئيس سابق
لاول مره في التاريخ الامريكي اذ قالت
السنه الجمهوريه ان خطوه من هذا النوع
ستفجر بلادنا ولنتحدث مشاهدينا عن مسار
التوجيه التهم هو مسار سري بامتياز
فاجتماع هيئه المحلفين التي ستقرر مصير
ترامب مغلق ومذكره الاتهام سريه حتى يوم
متون للرئيس السابق امام المحكمه في
منهاتن وبعد ان استمعت الهيئه لشهاده عدد
من الشهود شهود الدفاع والادعاء ابرزهم
محامي ترامبا السابق مايكل كوهين وهو شاهد
ادعاء الاساسي يتوقف توجيه التهم بجرم
جنائي للرئيس السابق على تصويت اثني عشر
من اصل 23 نوع من هيئه المحلفين لصالح هذا
المسار وحتى في هذه الحاله تبقى الكلمه
النهائيه في هذا الشان لمدعي عام مرهاتن
افنبراج وفي حال قرر ابراج المضيه قدما
بتطبيق قرار المحلفين سيتم اخبار الرئيس
السابق ومحاميه بقراره وفحو التهم
المواجهه في مذكره الاتهام ليبدا مسار
تفاوضى لتحديد كيفيه قدوم الترامب الى
نيويورك من فلوريدا وتسليم نفسه والمثول
في جلسه المحاكمه الاوليه هناك
ومدعي عامه
الذي يتحكم بمصر هذه القضيه قال ان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب تسبب
بتوقعات خاطئه بشان اعتقاله مضيفا ان
دوافع سياسيه وراء تصريحات ترامب وبرر
رفضه الموثول امام الكونفرس بالاشاره الى
ان التدخلات المشرعين في قضيه ترامب
انتهاك لقانون وسياده نيويورك كما ان
التطريحه الرئيس السابق دفعت الجمهوريين
للتدخل في التحقيقات
نتابع من امام محكمه الجنايات في منهات
جنوب نيويورك مع مراسل العربيه حسين طاود
حسين اهلا بك معنى اخر ما حصلت عليه من
معلومات حول قرار هيئه المحلفين واذا كانت
ستوجه اتهاما الى ترامب ام لا
تحيه لك صهيب الغموض هو سيد الموقف في هذا
الشان حتى الان من غير المعروف اذا كانت
الهيئه عندما تجتمع الاثنين او الاربعاء
او الخميس ستصوت على توجيه الاتهام هنا
يجب ان نعرف ان الهيئه يجب ان تنتهي اولا
من الاستماع الى كافه الشهود قبل ان يطلب
منها من قبل مكتب المدعي العام ان تصوت
على توجيه الاتهام ام لا ولكن هنا يحق
للدعي العام ان يقدم ادله جديده وان يطلب
الشهود جدد خاصه بعدما اعلن محامي ستار
ميدان ان موكلته حاولت عام 2018 او اتصلت
عام 2018 باحد محامي ترامب الان الذي
الذين يدافعون وهو جوتا كوبينا عندما كانت
تبحث عن محامي يمثلها واخبرته بمعلومات
سريه وهذه ولكن
الى مكتب
مدعي عمن هاتن بيت اسما يتك رر كثيرا في
الاخبار الان هو استدعي من قبل
اعضاء جمهوريين للمثول امام الكونغرس
بالنظر الى انه ديمقراطي واذا كان هناك
دوافع سياسيه وراء الرغبه في توجيه
الاتهام الى دونالد ترامب الجمهوري هنا
سؤال هل الفينبراج في ورطه
حتى الان لا يبدو كذلك وهو اجاب خلال
الرساله التي ارسلها الى رؤساء اللجان
الثلاثه التي طالبته بالادلاء بشهادته
وبتقديم الاتصالات والوثائق التي بحوزه
المكتب المدعي العام وقال بانه اولا هو
نفى ان تكون هذه التحقيقات مدفوعه بدوافع
سياسيه قال ان هذه لها دوافع قانونيه
وقضائيه هو يستطيع ان يرفض طلب الكونغرس
لان ليس للقنجرس السلطه على
سلطات انفاذ القانون هذا وفق الدستور هو
محمي دستوريا بهذا الشان ولكنه حتى الان
هو لم يرفض الاجتماع معهم ولكن قال يجب
اذا كان الاجتماع لن يكون من اجل تسليم
معلومات خاصه وهذا موقف وزاره العدل منذ
القدم انها لا تقدم معلومات خاصه خلال
تحقيق جاري للكونغرس لذلك هو حتى الان هو
محمي وهو ليس في ورطه
حسين طاوود مباشره من امام محكمه الجنايات
في منهات نيويورك
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه روسيا تبدا
تحصين دفاعاتها شرق اوكرانيا تحسبا لهجوم
مضاد
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد تزامنا مع اعلان القوات
المواليه لماوسكو والسيطره على سبعين
بالمئه من باخمت المدينه الاستراتيجيه شرق
البلاد اعلنت رئاسه الاوكرانيه ان الرئيس
الاوكراني
زار المواقع الاماميه لجيش بلاده قرب
باخموس بهدف رفع معنوية جنوده ثم زار
بعدها خرسون وفي التطورات الميدانيه افادت
المخابرات البريطانيه بان روسيا استعادت
السيطره جزئيا على الطرق المؤديه الى بلده
كريمينا بشرق اوكرانيا مشيره الى ان
القاده الروس يسعون لاستعاده مركز
كوبيانسك اللوجستي في خاركس بدورها ذكرت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان روسيا نفذت 48
غاره جويه وخمسه وسبعين هجوما صاروخيا في
الساعه الاخيره في احدث موجه من الضربات
الروسيه في
اما فيما يتعلق بالقرار الصادر عن المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه بحق الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين اعلن نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي ان القبض على الرئيس الروسي في
الخارج سيصبح سببا للحرب
علينا في البدايه ان نتفق على ان تنفيذ
القرار غير ممكن عمليا تخيلوا ان رئيسا
حاليا لدوله نوويه يصل الى المانيا مثلا
في زياره ثم يتم اعتقاله هذا يعتبر اعلان
حرب على روسيا وفي هذه الحاله ستقوم روسيا
بالرد عسكريا وستطير جميع الوسائل الممكنه
والصواريخ الى البونديستاج والى مكتب
المستشار وما الى ذلك
وفي حوار مع صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه
قلل الامين العام في شمال الاطلسيا في انه
سيتعين على الدول الغربيه دعم اوكرانيا
لفتره طويله في ظل الحرب فيها مضيفا ان
الرئيس روسيا فلاديمير بوتين لا يخطط
للتوصل للسلام انما يخطط لمزيد من الحرب
وفي واشنطن رد البيت الابيض على ما اسماها
الادعاءات الروسيه بشان تزويد اوكرانيا
بداخله تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم مؤكدا
ان الادعاءات الروسيه غير صحيحه وان
واشنطن لن تقدم لاوكرانيا
ذخيره تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم
وفيما يتعلق بخطي انابيب قال وزير
الخارجيه
لا تتوقع ان يكون تحقيق في انفجارات خطا
انابيب الغاز
العام الماضي شفافه
اعتقد ان هذه البلدان ستكون سعيده بنتيجه
نسميها باللغه الروسيه دفن الاطراف
السائبه لا اتوقع ان تكون تحقيقات شفافه
ولا نتوقع ان تكون النتائج متاحه لعامه
الناس
[موسيقى]
على طاوله الاتحاد الاوروبي في بروكسيل
ملفات عده سيناقشها قاده الدول 27 على
مدار يومين مساله الحرب في اوكرانيا
ووسائل تعزيز القدره التنافسيه لدى
الاقتصاد الاوروبي موضوعان على الجدول
الاعمال الرسمي لكن الخلافات الاخيره حول
السيارات والقطاع النووي ستفرض نفسها على
النقاشات بحسب الدبلوماسيين اذ تلقى
الخلافه الفرنسيه الالمانيه بشان موقع
الطاقه النوويه في مكافحه تغير المناخ
وحظر محركات الاحتراق الداخلي في عام 2035
بظلالها على القمه ومن المتوقع عقد اجتماع
ثنائي بين فرنسا والمانيا غدا الجمعه في
الوقت الذي تشهد العلاقات بين القوتين
الاوروبيتين توترات منذ اشهر وياتي ذلك في
وقت يواجه فيه الرئيس الفرنسي
احتجاجات عنيفه في فرنسا على قانون اصلاح
التقاعد فيما يواجه المستشار الالماني
استطلاعات راي متذبذبه اضافه الى انقسامات
في اختلافه
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه الامريكيه
للموافقه على تمويل بقيمه 150 مليون دولار
لانضمام الولايات المتحده مجددا الى
اليونسكو قائلا ان غياب بلاده عن هذه
المنظمه الامميه ترك الصين تستفرد بوضع
قواعد الذكاء الاصطناعي وفي ديسمبر العام
الماضي مهد الكونغرس عندما كان الحزب
الديمقراطي لا يزال مهيمنا عليها الطريق
امام واشنطن لاستعاده عضويه اليونسكو التي
تم تعليقها عام 2011
بسبب منح المنظمه الامميه دوله فلسطين
عضويه كامله
[موسيقى]
وفي اول ايام شهر رمضان المبارك بدات عده
توجيهات حكوميه تنفيذ خطط تشغيليه ضخمه في
الحرم المكي الشريف وتشمل الخطه تسهيل
طواف 107 الف معتمر في الساعه الواحده وسط
توقعات بتدفق ملايين المعتمد
[موسيقى]
اعداد مليونيه من المعتمرين والمصلين
يستقبلها المسجد الحرام بعد ان اعلنت
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين ان تشغيل الحرم المكي
بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه دون قيود طوال
شهر رمضان ويقابلها منظومه عمل موسع
[موسيقى]
هناك خطه مشتركه ابواب محدده لدخول المصلي
وابواب محدده لدخول المعتمر حتى يتم خروجه
من هذه الشعيره تقوم الرئاسه بما لديها من
مكونات ومن مستهدفات في خطتها بعرض جميع
محاور هذه الخطه حتى يقوم قاصد بيت الله
الحرام باداء نسخه بكل بكل يسر وسهوله
وبكل طمانينه خصصت رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين
اثني عشر الف موظف وعامل بالمسجد الحرام
وهيات اربعه عشر مسارا خاصا لدخول وخروج
المعتمرين والمصلين الى جانبي فتح كافه
التوسعات السعوديه الثلاث بالحرم المكي
وتوفير 9000 عربه كهربائيه ومتحركه
للتسهيل على كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه اضافه الى تسخير التقنيات والذكاء
الاصطناعي رحله المعتمد ورحله اللي اكتملت
جميع خدماته بمنظوماتها التكامليه
والارشاديه وغيرها بالتنسيق مع الجهات
الامنيه فيما يحقق الراحه لقاصدي بيت الله
الحرام تسعى الرئاسه من خلال كوادرها
البشريه المتفانيه بالخبرات التراكميه الى
وضع خطه تشغيليه مرنه لموسم رمضان هذا
العام مع الاخذ في الاعتبار لعوده اعداد
المعتمرين والمصلين الى ما قبل جائحه
فيروس كورونا من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الخميس الاسود
يشعل فرنسا قطع للطرق واشتباكات بين الامن
ومتظاهرين ضد قانون التقاعد
[موسيقى]
ادراك حقيقه ان العالم متغير باستمرار
يجعلك تشعر باهميه ان تعرف كل ما يدور من
حولك
في كل مكان وزمان من مصدر اخباري موثوق
يزودك بكل مجريات الاحداث
بامكانكم الان الاستماع الى العربيه اف ام
على الترددات التاليه
بالصوت يصلكم الخبر واكثر
خطوه واحده ليصبح الخيال واقعا بمركز
جراحات السمنه
بتقنياته المبتكره
المركز التخصصي الطبي رمز الثقه في
الرعايه الصحيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد نتابع من اثيوبيا مساعي
احياء السلام لا تزال متواصله فبعد شطب
البرلمان اسمها الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير
تيجراي من قائمه المنظمات الارهابيه اعلن
مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي ابي احمد عن
انشاء اداره مؤقته لمنطقه تيغراي وهي خطوه
رئيسيه في عمليه السلام عقب حرب استمرت
عامين في شمال البلاد وفق مراقبين
بوادر الحوار والمصالحه ترتسم معالمها في
اثيوبيا تزامنا مع رفع جبهه تحرير من
قائمه الجماعات المصنفه ارهابيا وانشاء
اداره مؤقته للمنطقه بعد قرابه سنتين من
الحرب التي استنزفت الطرفين خطوه من شانها
تعزيز السلام والاستقرار في البلاد اذا
تمكنت الاطراف من تعميم لغه الحوار مع
كافه الجماعات المسلحه تمشيا مع بنود
الاتفاق المبرم في نوفمبر الماضي مكتب
رئيس الوزراء اليثيوبي عينه
البارزه في جبهه التحرير تيجري رئيسا
للحكومه المؤقته وهي خطوه رئيسيه ستسمح
للجبهه بالعوده للساحه السياسيه وخلق ثقه
متبادله بين الاطراف
الاجراء وفق مراقبين للتطورات الحاصله
سيشجع اطرافا اخرى معارضه للمطالبه بازاله
اسمها عن لوائح الارهاب المحليه في
المرحله المقبله فالكثير من الاثيوبيين
يعملون في ان تدفع هذه الخطوه الى تسريع
تطبيق كافه مخرجات اتفاق السلام المبرم في
نوفمبر الماضي ووضع الاساس الصحيح الذي
يضمن العوده الى دوله مستقره وامنه بعد ان
شغل النزاع في تيجري طيله الفتره الماضيه
المجتمع الدوليه والمحلي
معنى من اديسه بابا الكاتب الصحفي عبد
الشكور عبد الصمد عبد الشكور اهلا بك معنا
في اخبار الساعه من العربيه بدايه هل هناك
اي رد فعل من جبهه التحرير تقراي على
تعيين احمد رضا رئيسا للاداره المؤقته في
منطقه تقراي
اهلا وسهلا بك اخي العزيز اهلا بمشاهديكم
الكرام
تعيين السيد
هو
باقتراح
وتسميه تسميته باقتراح من الجبهه الشعبيه
لتحرير
فبالتالي يعني اعتقد هذه خطوه يعني فيها
توافق داخلي فبالتالي ليس هناك اي يعني
اشكال
والسيد الدكتور بسيون الرئيس السابق
لتقييم اعلن بانه هناك نحن الان على
استعداد للاطلاق
لتاسيس المراه المرحله الانتقاليه طيب اذا
مدام هو من الشخصيات يعني
من اقليم تقراي وهذا التعيين يتوافق مع
اتفاق السلام الذي تم انضجه في بريتوريا
هل يمكن القول ان ازمه تيغراي انتهت او في
طريقها
للانتهاء دعنا نقول بعد هذه الاجراءات من
حكومه اديس ابابا
اعتقده هي هذه خطوه صحيح
يعني تمشي في الاتجاه الصحيح
فبالتالي يعني الحديث هناك في الاقليم وفي
وايضا حتى الاداره المركزيه في اديس اباظه
وهو الانطلاق على نحو اعاده الاعمار
واستكمال
خطوات السلام والمطالبه
[موسيقى]
بالحوار الوطني الذي
يعني نترقبه جميعا كاثيوبيين حتى يشمل
كافه القوى الاخرى
فبالتالي اعتقد يعني الكل يرغب بان يمشي
في هذه يعني العمليه
وانما هو بالاستعجال في في تنفيذ
واستكمال الاستحقاقات يا اخي العزيز ولكن
السيد عبد الشكور حتى يعني نفهم طبيعه هذا
الحل او هذا الاتفاق الذي انهى هذه الحرب
التي استمرت لسنتين بين اديس ابابا وبين
اقليم تيجراي ما هي تفاصيل ما نفهمه هو
عباره عن تقريبا حكم ذاتي لاقليم تيجراي
هكذا حله الامور وشطب جبهه تحرير تيغرام
من قوائم المنظمات الارهابيه في اديس
ابابا
تتمتع بحكم فيدرالي موسع الحكومه المركزيه
تتولى
حمايه الحدود
ويتعلق التخطيط الاقتصادي والتعليم
القضايا الرئيسيه فبالتالي اعتقد يعني هذا
هو المطالبه هو بتطبيق الدستور
ويعني حتى تمارس الاقاليم صلاحياتها
ضمن ما يسمع به
كيف سيكون شكل العلاقه بين اديس ابابا
يعني اعتقد يعني نحن الان ناخذ من
تسميه او موافقه رئيس الوزراء
للسيده
كحاكم للاداره المؤقته في الاقليم باعتبار
انه يعني الخضوع يعني وهناك حتى يكون هناك
انسجام توافق
فبالتالي اعتقد يعني هي هذه الصوره التي
يعني تمشي
تجربه يعني يجب ان يكون هناك توافق بين
الحكومه حكومه ابي احمد رضا شكرا جزيلا لك
عبد الشكور عبد الصمد الكاتب الصحفي كنت
معنا من اديس ابا
[موسيقى]
نذهب الى نزاع حول اقليم اخر هذه المره
وسط جهود لحل الصراحه حول اقليم ناغورني
كارباخ تجدد التوتر بين اذربيجان وارمينيا
اذ اعلنت يارافان مقتل احد جنودها في
تبادل الاطلاق النار مع قوه باكو في
المقابل نشرت وزاره الدفاع الاثريه فيديو
اتهمت فيه القوات الارمينيه بتحريك قطاعات
من منطقه تنتشر فيها قوات حفظ السلام
الروسيه قرب معبر حدودي يربط ارمينيا
بناغورني كراباخ وتسيطر عليه قوات اثريه
بدوره عرض وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في
اتصال مع رئيس اذربيجان الهام عاليه
المساعده لتسهيل محادثات سلام بين البلدين
داعيا الى اعاده فتح ممر لاتشين امام
المركبات التجاريه والخاصه
[موسيقى]
في فرنسا تمريره مشروع قانون لرفع سنه
التقاعد دون تصويت البرلمان عليه اثار
غضبا شعبيا عارما اذ امتلات شوارع العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس ومدن اخرى بالحشود
المعارضه لقرارات الرئيس الفرنسي
الاضرابات عرقله حركه السفر بعد ان اغلق
المحتجون محطات القطار ومطار شارل دو غول
وبعض المصافي والموانئ ففي العاصمه باريس
ومدينه غربا تجمع المتظاهرون واندلعت
المواجهات بين المحتجين وافراد الشرطه
الذين استخدموا خراطيم المياه لتفريق
الحشد الحكومه الفرنسيه بدورها قدرت عدد
المحتجين في الخميس الاسود باكثر من مليون
شخص ونتيجه لهذه الاضرابات تم اغلاق برج
ايفل وقصر بيرساي ايضا كما اغلق
المتظاهرون طرقا سريعه وتقاطعات الرئيسيه
لابطاء حركه السير بانحاء المدن الكبرى
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا ما نزل نتابع المشهد في
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس المشهد ما يزال
متوترا في هذا الخميس الاسود كما اصطلح
على تسميته اعلاميا مليون متظاهر خرجوا في
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس بشكل اساسي وعدد
كبير اخر من المدن الفرنسيه احتجاجا على
تمرير الحكومه الفرنسيه لقانون رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما دون
تمريره عبر البرلمان وهذا باستخدام ماده
للرئيس الفرنسي تخونه ذلك ما ادى الى
اندلاع احتجاجات عارمه اذا كما نتابع
الوضع ما يزال متوترا و ملتهبا في الشارع
الفرنسي حتى هذه اللحظات في الخميس الاسود
احتجاجا على قانون التقاعد الجديد
[موسيقى]
مدعي عن منهات يرفض الموت امام الكونجرس
للكشف عن نتائج التحقيق بقضيه ترامب
الفانتاجون يقرروا تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
ابرز من المخزون العسكري واوروبا تتعهد
بمليون قذيفه صاروخيه
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده دائما على
العربيه على صفحتنا على مواقع التواصل الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]